hello and welcome to inside the Oscars
I'm Rachel Smith actor bruce turn makes
a big return in today's best paper close
up as he and fellow oscar nominee june
squibb tell the academy the secrets of
bringing their vivid characters to life
in nebraska you don't really get hired
by alexander payne you get thought of
and then you get chosen and to be chosen
is a big deal for me so I didn't ever
feel I went to work for him I felt I
went to work with him and at the very
beginning he said don't show us anything
let us find it and that was the key to
me for the movie that's first time any
director had ever said that to me number
one and number two had put his money
where his mouth was and actually found
that we are now authorized to pay 1
million dollars to Woodrow T grantor
just trying to sell you magazines the
movie combines these highly seasoned
professionals and then local sort of
community theater actors and then a ton
of non-actors we pretty much follow
every lead you just never know can't
just drop everything and Drive to
Lincoln Nebraska Oh what else you got
gone on you know what I'm directing I
don't look at a monitor I stand by the
camera and when I say action I I kind of
mentally wish away the camera the
technicians and everything and kind of
and pretend I'm just watching the scene
and I'm asking myself constantly do I
believe it do i buy it does it feel
right I grew up in Illinois so i think
that when i read that script it was like
oh my god I know her I really knew who
this lady was and everybody else for
that matter there's something about all
these characters that feel very familiar
so you
them in various parts of your life you
know until we actually got out to
Nebraska I really over thought
everything and it got in my head about
stuff and and they were very good all
three of these wonderful people just
were so good to me and made me feel like
I was part of the group and it just
became this amazing experience there's
something about breaking through
emotionally and doing something selfless
and generous that you might have been
thwarted all your life until a certain
moment happens and you know Alexander
did a lot of careful shaping of the
script you know what Albert and I
responded to is the sense that you know
finally after things kind of decline in
a family there's a there's a chance for
renewal Thomas Wolfe said you know you
can't go home again you must go home
again because you got to look back and
who are you and who were they and why
didn't you communicate to him the way
you should over a vice versa I just
always felt that she loved woody it
never occurred to me the Kate didn't and
that this was just her way I never knew
the son of a [ __ ] even wanted to be a
millionaire should have thought about
that years ago and worked for it when
you go there it is kind of black and
white and in that area along with the
black and white comes an honesty and
integrity that you don't see on the
corridors along the big cities and
fairness I see what a little bit as a
monument to the keynote of all these
people which is they don't leave there
there are a hundred and seventy-five
years later for a reason hope you
enjoyed learning more about this samedi
tune in next week for another Best
Picture close-up see you soon